I have three programs set up on my computer for my true rife footbat. Two of them work great,
but the third one only lights for approximately half the time. Also the water is not dark when
I'm finished with that time allotted. Does this mean it's not working for the entire time?
Yet probably does mean it's not working for the entire time.
For both the true rife and the Italian Robin footbat, if the program stops working half way through,
that's usually a sign that there's too much salt in the water,
and you might want to start over with less salt. Understand the three footbat programs that I put in your
program for true rife users. You're not bound by that. You could go to the iron pro wave
folder and start using those programs. So if I were you, I just wouldn't stop using that third one
and do some other programs that you see appropriate for you in the iron pro wave folder.
But with your iron pro wave or your Italian Robin footbat, if you have that, if it stops working
half way through, that's usually an indication that you have too much salt in the water. Well,
how much salt am I supposed to put in the water? It depends on how hard your water is. So if
your water is really hard, we need you have a lot of minerals in your water. I can see I'm in
other earth minerals and iron and such. You're going to need less salt because salt is the helps
the conductivity through the water. If you are using reverse as most as water, which you shouldn't
be, but that's pretend your water is really pure like reverse as most as you're going to have to put
more salt in the water. So you're just going to have to play with this. Everybody is different.
You're there's no way to know that and tell you do that. So
now some people may be listening to this ago, I have an Italian Robin. How come I didn't get a
footbat? Because I don't recommend them for Italian Robin users users. The reason why I recommended
them for true rife users and quite honestly, it's a small percentage of true rife users that use it.
But true rife, you can only go up to 10,000 hertz with the Italian Robin you go up to 30,000 hertz.
You don't really need a footbat, you don't.